[Music]
thanks
here it's my fault let me hook you up
I'm Elaine 10 years ago we created the
robots who now do the tasks Americans
once did Thomas Newton was sentenced to
28 years after he had an illegal robot
devil of himself you hear that robot
yeah
[Music]
this new girl is different level I'm
glad you've met a nice young lady I need
you completely focused on getting a
horizontal for me put yourself a deep
program now see you too
Charles guy really wants to be used to
bang me so you'll have to take over
tomorrow too yes Elaine just
went
you too Byron E2 pick up your phone I've
never done this before
[Applause]
it also has a robot double you were
dating a robot all along you two and I
are running away together don't try to
stop us goodbye Elaine goodbye let's
just talk about this
don't do it
childish
this is terrible they've completely
stolen Our Lives
our real job we hunt them down and we
kill them um two cappuccinos thank you
you guys don't understand they're not
going to be obedient anymore
they're humanizing they're learning to
feel you want to get married immediately
let's go go away to stop our wedding
Joyride is over
hey I get to shoot me sorry I couldn't
resist well fine that I'm shooting you
that's not fair
swimming to shore oh my God oh my God I
shouldn't turn again
it's deep program now she's feral surely
want a Pinky Winky no tell me